jour alban bensa merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france comment est-ce
que vous analysez les tensions actuelles
en nouvelle calédonie je pense que les
tensions actuelles sont dues à la fin
que du référendum est nommé dans une
nouvelle phase si vous voulez dans la
préparation du troisième référendum et à
chaque fois que la nouvelle qualité doit
prendre en main son avenir d'une manière
ou d'une autre la question du nickel
resurgissement avec une exactement la
même chose en 1996 avant la signature de
l'accord de nouméa la question du nickel
et centrale puisque c'est le troisième
producteur mondial c'est la richesse
principale de la nouvelle calédonie et
sur cette richesse que pourraient
s'appuyer une émancipation complet de la
nouvelle caioni que la tutelle française
est justement le nickel représente 8% du
pib de la nouvelle calédonie avec la
vente de cette usine l'économie et
l'emploi sont ils réellement menacées
dans le territoire oui c'est à dire que
tout dépend qui reprend qui achètent ce
que chaque usine qui est vendu par
l'entreprise valait
un consortium brésilien si l'entreprise
usine est reprise par une organisation
économique et politique à majorité
calédonien toutes tendances politiques
et communautés confondues
à ce moment là on peut espérer que les
riches est de ces suppliques bénéficier
en nouvelle calédonie dans le cas
contraire ces richesses vont échapper au
budget la nouvelle calédonie ne vont
bénéficier qu'à une petite minorité et
vont laisser la nouvelle ka est de 10
ouverte à tous vents que l'économie de
marché généralisée donc c'est pour ça
que le vrai problème il est un problème
politique sociale il comment penser
l'avenir économique de la nouvelle
calédonie est ce cette situation
actuelle est une sorte de cas d'école et
il en sortira j'espère comme le souhaite
énormément de calédoniens loyalistes et
indépendantistes des négociations de
deux sont plus tard doit accompagner
mais il sent immédiatement de fel qu'est
ce qui pourrait apaiser les tensions
ce qui pourrait apaiser les tensions il
commence déjà sa poésie est un peu c'est
l'ouverture de négociations la mise à
plat doute aussi économique de la
nouvelle calédonie et dans ces
négociations que du point de vue il est
plus modérée déjà des pendentifs et des
loyalistes
puis j'ai changé pour trouver une
solution commune c'est dans ce sens que
monsieur perez que le président si du du
gouvernement américain et les nids sont
intervenus intervenu pour souhaiter
l'ouverture immédiate de négociations
qui d'ailleurs avait été produit par le
ministre de l'outre-mer intuition me
sébastien lecornu qui donc avait déjà
posé des jalons de cette négociation
donc il faut absolument garder le cas du
dialogue
de violents affrontements ont éclaté en
début de semaine entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre ce qu'on peut craindre
à nouveau des heures
si le dialogue n'est pas renouer alors
c'est vrai que je suis un affrontement
sont particulièrement violent et va
paraître un peu comme déplacée dans un
contexte l'idée de référendum se sont
très bien apprécié ou alors il y fit pas
jouer sur les stratégies de tension
effectivement il ya eu six affrontements
qui déjà véritablement a organisé il ya
une sorte d'exaspération de tous les
calédoniens et du coup toutes les
confrontations près de vienne
disproportionnée par rapport aux enjeux
et c'est tout à fait regrettable le
chantier pas avancer le dossier est une
nouvelle manifestation des deux prévues
aujourd'hui à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre selon vous je ne suis pas je
pense que les calédoniens savent aussi
après ce qu'ils ont vécu de terribles il
ya une trentaine d'années gérer ce genre
de situation pour qu'elle ne dégénère
pas car si elles dégénèrent où les
calédoniens sont perdants merci alban
bensa d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes anthropologue
spécialiste de la nouvelle calédonie et
de la culture kanak également